so a lot of people don't realize about
alias grace is that actually based off a
novel considered to be historical
fiction which sounds really weird but it
actually makes complete sense in this
case grace Marx and James McDermott were
real people and they were both convicted
of the murder of Thomas Kinnear and they
were also suspected of killing Nancy
Montgomery just like in the show
McDermott was actually hung in real life
and grace Marx was actually sentenced to
life after 30 years grace Marx was
pardoned she moved to upstate New York
and no one knew what happened to her
after that just fell off the face of the
earth so that's where Margaret Atwood
1996 wrote this novel Elias Grace where
she took the true events and true
characters and fictionalized what she
thought might have happened but she did
create a completely fictional character
and dr. Simon Jordan and that's why this
makes sense as a historical fiction
piece because he's that basically
bringing that path to let Margaret
Atwood create what she thinks might have
happened and get into the mind of grace
Marx so it's a really cool concept I
actually don't know any works like this
I was impressed I was watching sure I
didn't realize was based off true events
thought it was all completely written
and the most important scene to me was
the hypnosis scene with Jeremiah and
grace I feel like for viewers watching
the show that scene could be a real hit
or miss it's a lot to take in one of
those scenes we were watching other
people like I was you kind of look at
each other like what is going on which I
love cuz it was a curveball and it makes
you relate to the people in the room
watching grace Marx in this scenario but
the best part about this to me was left
for interpretation to what was really
happening did grace Marx just go with
Jeremiah knowing that if she appeared
insane that it would set her free or was
she seriously hypnotized and he was
really exposing a true case of multiple
personality in grace Marx letting Mary
come out I don't know but to me that's
effective cuz it makes you think and it
doesn't just give you all the answers it
kind of lets you decide from all the
evidence you've been given beforehand
another scene a lot of people were
talking about Joe wasn't crazy about was
dr. Jordan having angry sex with his
house made out of anger towards not
getting grace marks and he says that
horrible thing to her well you're not
the one I want to do that - I felt like
it was out of character for him and no
he was a man of lust as well but I felt
like it was totally just to serve the
purpose of like oh and here's another
guy thought was good but he's bad I
really like dr. Jordan here and I
thought he was a protagonist in this and
it just felt kind of forced in there and
such a dramatic turn for him to do that
and it made him hateable I don't think
it was necessary really added anything
to do that I think he just leave him as
be because that's an extreme thing he
did that was really bad and to throw
that in there and end his story on that
and that sad note I'm not crazy about
that that's one of my few complaints
about this great show it's just perfect
timing that Handmaid's Tale alias grace
is coming out in The Times burn right
now with all the controversies in
Hollywood with us progressing a society
towards how we treat woman how we treat
each other sexually and what's okay and
what's not okay and it effectively shows
you how basically every man in this
woman's life lusted after her at one
point from her father being a creep and
less thing after her and abusing her and
partisan being a creep obviously to her
friend Mary and then to her trying to
get in the door and then Kinnear do you
know he was a good guy but then he
creeps on her and the worst part
probably hardest part to watch was the
doctor to mental institute seriously
raping her terrible stuff there it
really opens your eyes to stuff like
this and how much just happens even
today still and how it affects people in
their head when he'd you screwed up
stuff like this to them perfect sample
being alias grace she was so tough
through all this stuff growing up that
was happening to her that was awful and
then she found joy for once in life with
Mary and when Mary died that's when she
just jumped and that's what was so
effective to me about the story now they
filmed that where with the window
opening and she's like let me in
basically was that shift to another
personality shake became Mary that's
when the t'me got very interesting super
dark and I mean you could say when Mary
Whitney died she was reborn and grace
died in that moment she just took on a
version of Mary that was even more
intense and guarded in a way and that's
why I believe hypnosis you Jeremiah he
was bringing out that feeling in her
that deep truth fully and opening like
they say in the peach getting to the
seed that was it and for Sarah Gordon
the actress of grace to really pull all
this off and kind of not fully show how
she's turned and then ease into it and
keep herself mysterious really should be
applauded such a challenging role to
have kind of the split personality going
but not fully showing it and not
overdoing overboard because you can do
that in something like this I really
feel like she didn't at all and she
should be definitely worthy of award
consideration what I really liked about
this show it didn't have any oh my god
moments that's not believable or that's
really cheesy where at some points with
handmade still have you seen I did
complain a little bit that there was
those moments this show I didn't feel
any of those so really good job on the
production here with this keeping it
really true and consistent tone here and
I didn't feel like there was one actor
actress here who did a bad job it was
consistent and great acting all around
what I loved about this was there was
only six episodes there about 40 minutes
each they weren't too long it feels like
no second of the show was wasted every
scenes important there's no filler here
you think more shows need to do
especially thing to be on Netflix or
Hulu a lot of binge were these shows
just have way too much filler now and I
think we're over using that term as
anyone can binge of show is just
watching much episodes in a row but is
it worthy he's worthy of avenged this
show clearly is I figure if it was
former episodes we've been too much and
you probably would have gotten bored or
want to get to the point of it I think
it evenly timed out well there wasn't a
dud of an episode I thought I just got
better and better as it went on and like
handmade tail was super focused both
kept a super strong idea of where it's
going and they get to it I think my only
problem with this story and it's not
really the show's fault but there's that
part where you kind of feel cold after
watching this a little empty inside and
there's no one you're really rooting for
so that kind of makes this a little
tough of a watch doesn't mean it's bad
it's just entertainment value goes down
a little bit there because the feeling
of connecting someone kind of really is
not there with this story it's no
Handmaid's Tale but it's really well
done I really enjoyed it it's only
miniseries so there's no season 2 or
anything did what I need to do beautiful
set design beautiful costumes great
makeup great acting all around and an
awesome lead and great music as well so
to me that gives this an 8 wasn't
amazing wasn't something I want to keep
watching but was worth my time it's
definitely somebody to check out if you
haven't seen it if you have I really
want to know what everyone thinks about
forming questions to me this show left
you with which was you everything braced
every came grace again at the end after
she was pardoned or she always just this
broken version of Mary but she really
hypnotized or did she fake it and she
really killed Kinnear and his
housekeeper I certainly believe if she
did but I wanted to see what you guys
think and another thing like people are
asking was did she ever end up looking
for her siblings she had left early in
this story I think a lot of people
forgot about that but in real life no
one knows I mean she fell off the face
of the earth when she got part in so
let's just jump to our theories here do
we think she would do that or do we
think because it's old in time there's
not like obviously faced with something
to look people up so maybe it's more on
her siblings to know that she got
pardoned because she's the famous one in
the newspapers do you think they
resented her and didn't even try to
reach out to her what do you think
happened there so let's get these
debates going down below or respond to
everyone let me know we thought and
please keep coming back for more do a
ton of TV shows movie reviews celebrity
interviews and trailer reactions as well
and I also reviewed handmade tail up
there which you can check out but please
please subscribe and please comment
below and keep coming back